there's actually a really nice
software that people should check out
like a service uh
it's using machine learning really
nicely for podcast editing
where you can it learns
the voice of the speaker and it can
change the words you said it's like some
deep fake stuff it's deep fake but
for positive applications it's very
interesting it's like the only deep fake
positive applications i've seen i have a
friend who's obsessed with defects yeah
what's great about i think deep fakes
is that it's gonna do the opposite of
sort of what's happening with our
culture
where everyone will have plausible
deniability yeah exactly i mean that
that's the hope for me is
there's so many fake things out there
that we're going to actually be much
more skeptical
and and think and take in multiple
sources and
actually like reason like use common
sense and use them like deep
thinking to understand like what is true
and what is not because
uh you know we used to have like
traditional sources like the new york
times and all these kinds of
publications that had a reputation there
are these institutions and they're the
source of truth
and when you no longer can trust
anything as a source of truth
you start to think on your own i guess
part of the individual that goes
it takes its way back to like where i
came from the soviet union where you
can't really trust any one source of
news
you have to think on your own you have
to talk to your friends tremendous
amount of
intellectual autonomy don't you think
think about the societal consequences
absolutely i mean we see so much
decentralization in all
aspects of our digital lives now but
this is like
the decentralization of thought
you could say it's sadly or i don't
think it's sad it's decentralization of
truth
where like truth is a clustering thing
where you have these like this point
cloud of people just swimming around
like billions of them and they all have
certain ideas
and what's thought of as truth is almost
like a clustering algorithm when you
just get a bunch of
people that believe the same thing
that's truth but there's also another
truth
and there might be like multiple truths
and it's almost
be like a battle of truths maybe even
the idea of truth
will like lessen its power in society
that there is such a thing as a truth
because like the downside of saying
something is true
is uh it's always the downside of
what people like religious people call
scientism which is like
once science has declared something is
true
you can't no longer question it but
the reality is science is a moving
mechanism you're constantly questioning
you're constantly questioning and
maybe truth should be renamed
as uh as a process not a
not a final destination the whole point
is to keep questioning keep questioning
keep discovering
kind of like we're going backwards in
time so like
back when back when people were sort of
finding their identities and we were
less globalized right
like people would would get together and
they'd get together around common value
system
common morals and a common place and
those would be sort of these clusters of
their truth right and so we have all
these different like civilizations and
societies across
across the world that created their own
truths you know we talk about the jews
and the tom and toro
look at buddhist texts we can look at
all sorts of different truths and
how many of them get at the same things
but many of them have different ideas or
different articulations
yeah harare and sapiens rewinds that
even farther back into like caveman
times that's the thing that made us
humans special
is who can develop these clusters of
ideas hold them in their minds
through stories pass them on to each
other and it grows and grows and finally
we have bitcoin
so which money is another belief system
that
um that that has power
only because we believe in it and is
that truth
i don't know but it has power and it
it's it's carried in the minds of
millions
and thereby has power
you